the fbi has confirmed that they are
going to create a dedicated national
cryptocurrency unit now the fbi
obviously one of the largest national
law enforcement agencies in the united
states they are taking crypto seriously
here's exactly what this unit is going
to be doing the unit is called the
virtual asset exploitation unit it's
going to centralize the agency's
cryptocurrency expertise into one single
group of folks they're going to look at
blockchain analysis they're going to do
virtual asset seizure and they're going
to train the rest of their organization
they also are going to be investigating
ransomware and other crimes with tools
using those analysis of a public
blockchain they're going to seize assets
involved in crimes as well ultimately if
we listen to exactly what they're saying
here's a quote that describes why
they're taking this so seriously deputy
attorney general lisa monaco said i
think we are sending a message that
cryptocurrencies and virtual currencies
should not be considered a safe haven
asset now of course that is true i've
been saying for a very long time the
choice currency of criminals around the
world for money laundered terrorists and
also nefarious actors is the us dollar
it's physical cash untraceable
decentralized transactions bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they require you to use
a public immutable ledger literally
every single time you use these assets
it is written into history cannot be
changed cannot be hidden anyone in the
world can audit those results if you're
a criminal and you're committing a crime
with your fingers on a keyboard it's
highly likely that law enforcement will
be able to track you down now of course
law enforcement they also have a lot of
work to do they just announced a brand
new director for this organization what
we see here is that the justice
department is announcing the first
director of the national cryptocurrency
enforcement team the ncet the ncet
according to this press release will
enhance the criminal division's existing
efforts to provide support and training
to federal state local and international
law enforcement to build capacity to
aggressively investigate and prosecute
serious crimes involving cryptocurrency
and digital assets in the u.s and around
the world now they aren't just waking up
to this the justice department fbi the
department of defense and many other law
enforcement agencies in the united
states have been paying attention for a
long time we know of stories like the
silk road but also if we look at the
year-over-year percentage growth in
value received by service from illicit
addresses defy has exploded there's some
mining explosion as well ultimately as
more and more people use bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies of course criminals are
going to use it as well but we've seen
study after study after study show that
less than half of one percent
of the actual activity on a blockchain
is coming from illicit or nefarious
actors now of course in the legacy world
two trillion dollars a year of fiat
currency is laundered every single year
and so ultimately bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies criminals are waking up
it's a really bad form of money to use
to commit a crime now law enforcement is
beefing up their capabilities they've
got more tools more people and more
funding and ultimately what i think
we're going to see is that bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies criminals are going to
run away from they're going to still
want to use cold hard cash because
ultimately that's the last untraceable
money available hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time